el 7 de enero de 2015 dos hombres
armados entran en las oficinas parisinas
de charlie hebdo es el día de la
conferencia semanal casi todo el mundo
está presente a las 1133 los atacantes
abrieron fuego 34 disparos de
kalashnikov el número de víctimas es
elevado 11 muertos y cuatro heridos
graves mientras subían los dos hombres
ejecutaron a un policía a sangre fría
rápidamente la identidad de los dos
hombres se hace pública los hermanos
cohen sí conocidos por los servicios de
inteligencia desaparecen en el aire
mientras un tercer hombre aterroriza a
la capital el 8 de enero ha médico lee
para lee un criminal convicto mata a una
policía municipal al día siguiente a la
1 05 de la tarde entra en un
supermercado judío de panzer armado con
dos rifles de asalto durante cuatro
horas retiene a 18 personas después de
matar a tres clientes y a un miembro del
personal al mismo tiempo a 50 kilómetros
de parís los hermanos cohen skip toman
como rehén al director de una imprenta
en sennett mago los servicios de
inteligencia descubrieron rápidamente el
vínculo entre los tres terroristas
a las cuatro menos diez las fuerzas de
seguridad especial asaltaron dagma tongo
el y unos minutos más tarde el
supermercado y perca ser los tres
asaltantes mueren bajo las balas todos
los rehenes están sanos y salvos el
balance de estos tres días de terror 17
muertos y docenas de heridos algunos con
graves secuelas y traumas el histórico
juicio que se llevará a cabo hasta el 10
de noviembre intentará responder a las
muchas preguntas de las víctimas y sus
familiares 14 personas están siendo
procesadas por complicidad terrorista 11
están presentes en el tribunal
los otros tres parientes de américo y
bali están bajo una orden de arresto
internacional su poseído lukas este
juicio tiene un deber de reparación y de
verdad para con las víctimas en
particular debe ser una oportunidad para
mostrar las cosas nombrar los hechos y
permitir que las víctimas entiendan cómo
sucedieron las cosas y por qué
sucedieron en primer lugar es el deber
de la institución judicial revelar la
verdad
el juicio será filmado en su totalidad
de manera excepcional con fines
históricos